In today’s day and age, one of the pastimes
of movie fans is theorizing on the Internet.
With so many big projects being produced under
the watchful eye of social media users, everybody’s
got a hypothesis of what might happen in the
latest Hollywood tentpoles.
Speculating is a great deal of fun, but there
are times when it doesn’t amount to anything.
Learn why it’s always important to keep
those grains of salt handy in our video, 10
movie theories that fans (or the Internet)
were completely wrong about.
WARNING.
This video will contain spoilers for Captain
America: Civil War and Batman V Superman.
Captain America: Civil War
Since the third Captain America film was a
loose adaptation of the Civil War comic, many
were curious to see how far the Russos would
go in bringing the panels to life.
The famous story arc ends with the death of
Steve Rogers, and there were rumors suggesting
the Civil War movie would be bookended by
funeral scenes.
This led many to believe that Rogers would
perish on the big screen – before a triumphant
revival in a later film.
But when the credits rolled, the Star Spangled
Man was still alive, hiding in Wakanda as
a fugitive.
Chris Evans is so great in the role, we’re
happy he’s sticking around.
Batman V Superman
With the DCEU introducing viewers to a grizzled,
experienced Batman, it’s evident that this
Dark Knight has been through a lot and lost
some allies along the way.
The marketing made it clear that Jason Todd’s
Robin had been killed at some point, but some
reports indicated Gotham’s police commissioner
Jim Gordon was also gone by the time the film
started.
Thankfully, that wasn’t true, and the character
will appear in Justice League, portrayed by
Oscar winner J.K. Simmons.
Gordon is such an icon in the Batman mythos,
it would be a waste if the DCEU never featured
him at all.
Batman V Superman
Zack Snyder drew some criticisms for his take
on Superman nemesis Lex Luthor, but there
could have been even more outcries if some
rumors about the character proved true.
It was speculated that Jesse Eisenberg’s
Lex was living on the streets at age 14 and
was overseeing a street gang at 15.
He was also allegedly into tattoos, and had
a sleeve of the Metropolis skyline down his
arm.
In actuality, Luthor inherited LexCorp after
his father died and looked to develop anti-Kryptonian
technology.
Fans were already turned off by Eisenberg’s
little quirks, so who knows what the reaction
to a tatted-up, street smart Lex would have
been.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Luke Skywalker was noticeably absent from
all the marketing materials for this anticipated
sequel, and many fans were wondering why.
Some theorized that the original trilogy hero
had succumbed to the Dark Side, and Disney
was saving that as a massive reveal for the
final film.
A popular belief was that Luke had become
Kylo Ren, and the announcement of Adam Driver’s
casting was just an elaborate bait-and-switch.
Turns out, Luke is still a Jedi Knight and
the reason for him not being in any trailers
was that he’s just in one scene: the last
one.
That would have been a big spoiler to share
in promotional materials.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Back when the basic plot to Episode 7 was
unknown, fans were left to their own devices
to concoct a story.
One bit of speculation proposed that Kylo
Ren was trying to resurrect the villain Darth
Vader since he idolized the Dark Lord so much,
and the heroes would have to work to stop
that from happening.
Bringing people back from the dead doesn’t
appear to be in Kylo’s plans, as he just
craves the power of the Dark Side.
In the end, it’s good this was false.
Vader is an intricate part of Star Wars history,
but it’s time for the new generation to
shine.
James Bond
Longtime James Bond fans are familiar with
one of the more famous Internet theories:
James Bond is actually a code name given to
different individuals.
This explains why the character changes physical
appearance every so often and is still a relatively
young man 50 years into his career.
Yet, evidence proves it false.
A scene in Skyfall depicts Bond’s childhood
home, where the tombstones of his parents
are present.
Both mother and father are named Bond, meaning
that’s 007’s real name.
As for why he keeps telling everyone it, we’ll
leave that up to you.
Jurassic World
It wasn’t enough for Jurassic Park fans
that Hollywood’s new favorite leading man
Chris Pratt was starring in Jurassic World;
they had to craft a whole backstory for his
new character.
Some believe that Pratt’s Owen is an adult
version of the child Dr. Alan Grant terrorizes
with a raptor claw in the original film.
The “proof” is that Grant told the boy
to show the raptors “respect,” and Owen
has a line in Jurassic World where he mentions
his relationship with the raptors is “based
on respect.”
It’s a stretch, and there’s no further
evidence in the film that supports it.
This one’s most likely wishful thinking.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Back when the basic plot to Episode 7 was
unknown, fans were left to their own devices
to concoct a story.
One bit of speculation proposed that Kylo
Ren was trying to resurrect the villain Darth
Vader since he idolized the Dark Lord so much,
and the heroes would have to work to stop
that from happening.
Bringing people back from the dead doesn’t
appear to be in Kylo’s plans, as he just
craves the power of the Dark Side.
In the end, it’s good this was false.
Vader is an intricate part of Star Wars history,
but it’s time for the new generation to
shine.
Ferris Bueller’s Day Off
Ever since Ferris, Cameron, and Sloane made
Chicago their playground, moviegoers have
had one question: which specific day did they
take off?
Using the information from the Cubs game the
trio attends, fans have pointed to June 5,
1985 as the exact date, but that doesn’t
add up.
There’s a famous sequence where Ferris sings
during the Von Steuben Day Parade, which is
typically held on or around September 17 – not
in the middle of summer.
This means that the June 5, 1985 theory is
incorrect, and John Hughes just devised a
composite day for the purposes of his film,
which is just fine by us.
The Dark Knight Rises
The finale to Christopher Nolan’s Batman
trilogy was no stranger to the rumor mill
as anticipation heated up.
A leaked set photo teased a potential plot
development that never game to be.
Depicting a green-screened pit in the desert,
some thought that the image was showing the
Lazarus Pit, which in the comics brought Ra’s
al Ghul back to life.
In the end, there was a pit in The Dark Knight
Rises, but it was Bane’s torturous underground
prison and not the Lazarus.
Since Nolan’s franchise was steeped in reality,
a magic pit always seemed like a farfetched
inclusion.
Captain America: Civil War
Audiences met Hawkeye’s family in Avengers:
Age of Ultron, and some thought they could
be brought back for a tragic return in Civil
War.
Reports indicated that the villain Crossbones,
played by Frank Grillo, would murder Hawkeye’s
wife and children, leading to a fight between
Crossbones and the sharp shooter.
Hawkeye would eventually win by killing his
enemy with four arrows – one for each dead
family member.
Civil War was heavy enough as it was with
collateral damage and superhero guilt complexes.
The last thing we needed was a takeout of
an entire family, so it’s good this was
false.
Those are our picks for movie theories the
Internet got wrong.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!